50 years ago, external hard drives were the
size of refrigerators.
Today, they squeeze a lot more memory into
drives the size of chocolate bars.
On the hard drive assembly line.
There's not a speck of dust.
An air filtering system sucks particles out
of the air to keep them from contaminating
the drive and compromising its function.
Production starts with the motor base.
An employee installs a voice coil magnet.
It's one of two that will move the drive
heads to write information on rotating disks.
They're called voice coils because they
operate on the same principle as
loudspeakers. Next, a robot places one of
the hard drive disks in the motor base.
A camera snaps a photo to send information
to guide the robot so it positions the disc.
Exactly. Another robot places a round metal
spacer at the center of the disc, again
relying on the camera's eye for guidance.
It sets a second disc on top of the spacer.
This is a two disc hard drive, but a drive
can have several depending on the amount of
storage needed.
A robot locks the discs into place with a
stainless steel clamp.
This next part is a plastic ramp.
The ramp is a place to park the disk, drive
heads when they're not engaged in reading and
writing data. Those tiny heads have been
preassembled to one end of the head
arm. They attach the other end of the arm to
the lower voice coil in the base and then
situate the second voice coil above it.
To maintain its squeaky clean interior.
A robot inserts a thin cotton filter.
This filter will capture dust particles in
the event that some infiltrate the hard
drive. A robot now places a metal cover on
the other side of the drive.
Another robot then screws the cover to the
motor base.
With the inner workings now encased, the
hard drive can be moved out of the air
filtered section of the factory.
A worker collects the hard drive assemblies
and slots them into a tote box.
Once the circuit board has been added, they
transfer the hard drives to a test chamber
behind the closed door of the chamber.
A robot swings into action.
It plucks a hard drive from the tote box and
plugs it into a test cell to confirm that
it's functional. Outside employees go about
their daily business as the robot
methodically tests each hard drive in the
tote boxes.
Once a tote of drives is confirmed to be
operational, the chamber ejects them and a
worker then does a visual inspection of each
one.
She looks for scratches or other damage that
could hinder its function.
There's another slightly different system
for testing in this one.
The employee places each drive on a conveyor
that delivers it to a robot tester.
Having two tester systems ensures that if
one goes down, they still have another one to
carry on. After all, like humans, robots are
not infallible.
At the packing station.
Now, there's one last visual inspection.
The employee scans the drive's serial number
so its production can be traced in the event
of a problem later.
She then seals it in plastic.
This hard drive is now ready to accept data
and ensure that someone doesn't totally lose
it if their computer drive crashes.